not fair to ask you a question but music  is totally intrinsic to your pictures to  all of them they're about music in a way  and I since you helped you did this  wonderful job of helping to put this  together what what I always want to ask  you what is it about music and movies  that totally connect for you I think  it's it's it's just a magic that happens  sometimes when the right song matches  the right scene you can't always tell  when it's going to work I'm still amazed  in coming home where you can see coming  home and all of those songs are so well  known but house work is so personal that  the songs feel like they were written  for a house movie and and that's just  part of the magic that can happen  sometimes and and I think you go on a  search and you have to love music and  when somebody gets it right you just  feel it way down deep and you never  forget the scene the song where you were  when you saw it and that's probably why  we're here tonight to experience that in  you